everybody in the office thinks that we
have like crushes on each other everyone
the comments in the video student I
don't have feelings for tomorrow you
wanted to be single for a long time and
I didn't want to cross the line between
co-worker and no no no I had rules and
the rules work I need to be single for
year and my rule and no euro was I'm
going to marry this woman someday and I
will do anything in my power to make it
happen at the beginning of 2019 I was
coming out of a three and a half year
relationship I was about to embark on
this huge journey from the BuzzFeed
office in New York riot been for three
years to the BuzzFeed office in LA
moving to LA was like immersing myself
in everything new my family's not here
all my friends I've had forever aren't
here one friend I had here with me that
was a saving grace is Rachael Merle
coming out to LA newly single the best
way I could describe it is she was like
an unbridled stallion she just was going
out on the weekdays livin it up she was
kind of like in a new city she just
wanted to be meeting new people going to
new places and not getting involved in
anything serious that was like the
farthest thing from her mind the former
all came along my dating life was quite
eclectic I was either not making myself
available to people or I'll just throw
myself at people who were clearly not
compatible for me
it wasn't clear to me at first that he
was desperate to find love until he
started making projects over and over
again about finding love and people
around the office wondering why is he
using the company's resources to find
love when I watched Aria date a couple
people it was clear that he was very
romantic and loving and giving but it
never looks marked so after having
dabbled in the dating world for a bit at
a sort of last year I decided to just
focus my energy on a personal challenge
and if you haven't seen or haven't heard
me talk about it a hundred times in
previous videos I trained I fought in an
MMA fight last year but then of course
during this period is one Morel strolled
into the BuzzFeed office
here in LA when I moved to the LA office
we had a weekly meeting my whole video
team would come together the first time
ever the team meeting is a team check-in
yeah and this man would be flustered
huffing in and out of the meeting I had
training oh sorry I'm gonna be late oh I
can't even make it or you just write in
the group message to be like sorry I had
another training today was the only day
I could do it and I remember thinking
he's a liar he doesn't want to go to
this meeting I just thought he was like
this really aloof two self-involved
egomaniac
which is also not totally incorrect she
saw how cute I wasn't a few of the
meetings and so she wanted to see more
of it so she's very upset and
disappointed I did think he was cute
slowly you know we'd message each other
over slack or in company messaging
system Morell couldn't get enough of me
let me know I wanted to see more so she
messaged me good producer so I wanted to
help at first it was more about work
stuff but it's slowly we throw in since
banter every now and then and there's
some clear at least digital chemistry
between us both then I dropped a casual
suggestion maybe you want to come sit
with the team and this man came up and
then became a permanent installment was
it entirely because they you because
Megan went on sick leave me and Ari I
used to sit together on this one couch
away from our desks I left to have a
surgery done so I was out of work for
like a month
and during that time because I wasn't
there Aria chose to go sit at his
regular desk and that's where Merle says
and so really I brought them together so
then we enter the phase of Merle and
Aria talking 12 hours every day all day
I said right next to them and I watched
this notation blossom and it was pretty
adorable but also annoying it was just
like all day long it was so easy to just
like talk about genuinely any topic we
would joke about murder horror films
just seemed like we had a lot in common
first time I really saw the tension
between Ari and Merle was when Ari and I
were filming the follow-up video to his
MMA video where we kind of talked about
the behind the scenes
they were so flirty jack was seeing a
lot of sparks between us no idea what he
saw he's been I'm a perv yeah you are at
that point I was like they're gonna date
like I'd never seen Aria act like that
this interview ended with a hug that I
thought would end any romantic
interactions between us I remember
hugging each of the interviewees after
their interview and so I said to Murrow
you know it's gonna be kind of weird
because I had both of them here and I
hugged both of them afterwards let's get
this awkward moment in history I was
like okay here's your hug and I gonna
hug this man and he clings on to me for
dear life like moths Jesus Christ well
you smell like you cut a little handle I
practically choked me out behind the
camera I was just like because it was
just so like tense between the two you
could tell that they had the hots for
each other
and I even told all right as soon as we
finished that video I was like what's
going on with me too and he denied it
he's like oh no like we're just friends
I remember I told Jack cheese my
coworker like I don't believe I don't
believe that at all you were probably
really what's a good thing let's look at
the footage again I was like do you guys
hang out he's like yeah sometimes we'll
stay late at work together for it till
like ten piano-like
I stay really late sometimes when
there's a lot of work and I started
realizing that merlin arya were also
staying late they would work late and it
would actually just be them hanging out
until like 11:00 p.m. and maybe getting
like 30 minutes worth of work done these
after our hangouts kind of now that i
look back at them were basically pseudo
dates i remember those nights they were
like these brief periods were and felt
like time froze it was just us in the
office enjoying each other's company and
it was wonderful
i've never openly and actively pursued
some of the way i did with you and it
was because we were just so open about
the fact we were flirting with each
other's i remember openly addressing the
fact that we flirted with each other and
aria was like shocked by that first ice
told him that i think he flirts with
everyone I don't think I'm that much a
flirt aria is a [ __ ] [ __ ] I at one
point was like well me and you flirted
all the time and who's kind of like oh
my god yeah I guess so
and so I feel like that's sort of like
transitioned us into this new fangled
territory where was like okay we're
openly flirting with each other
obviously we're interested in each other
but I was still genuinely dead set on
doing my own thing not getting involved
with anyone but aria he was obviously
pursuing me I realized that Aria had an
infatuation with Merle when they showed
up on set for a video that I was a Dean
they were awful together to be around
Aria has got a type of energy just in
general which you can kind of you know
find the frequency and understand it but
it was off the charts around her
annoying in fact and I'm not afraid to
say that there were rumors flying all
over the office and the internet that
Aria and I were together I kept seeing
them together around the office and I
was like oh my god I think they're a
thing from my desk I really see
everything if there's a love beginning I
usually know and I'm just saying I saw a
lot I feel like I was able to really
hone in
Aria and whorls relationship because I
met my fiancé at work and it was just
the same exact thing was happening in
front of my eyes I messaged Aria and
said basically you guys are a thing it's
obvious everybody knows he says
something like oh we're just two
professional coworkers and then I told
him that that's exactly how my
girlfriend Sadie and I talked six years
ago one of the big days where I realize
how special it was the day we want and
film the road trip video with Jack boy I
was third-wheeling hard there were so
many times where they would like look at
each other and smile and like they would
laugh at like jokes that didn't even
make sense or I didn't even understand I
fully knew that they would date and get
married and have kids
we'd never spend a prolonged period of
time outside of the office together so I
thought you know what if it's awkward
after a little bit a lot of fun and you
shouted with me in public all of the
yelling and screaming and this is my
world that Aria does this is my wife
sometimes I think it's really funny and
sometimes it makes people really
uncomfortable but Merle is like the only
person who really loves it you know that
thing they say about when you love
someone you love them for their flaws
one of my favorite things that Aria said
to Merle he said to her Merle you just
moved to LA you're in season 1 you have
to go around and date I'm your season 3
guy and I just thought that was so cute
and so funny and I was like oh my god
like Merle I love him but Merle was
still dating and she was not thinking of
aria that way my first initial reaction
to the thought of me and aria
romantically was like overwhelmed it was
mostly because I was in a phase where I
wanted only casual relationships I
didn't want a long-term serious
relationship and Aria is not a casual
guy I thought it was like an
all-or-nothing type situation everybody
was whispering and Aras eared asking him
all the time like has anything happened
is anything going on with you and Merle
meanwhile I'm catching like hints of
this and sorry
one time me and Merle and Megan went out
for dinner we asked her Merle was it tea
do you like aria she said he's cute
but I wouldn't date him and look at that
I just didn't like it put too much
pressure I go thrust me out and it was
really public like people on the
Internet I've never even met we're like
saying things in all the comments in any
videos we were in together which can be
nice but at the time was overwhelming
yeah a little bit now yeah
of course all fun things have to come to
an end this man threw a temper tantrum I
got through it
him pretension finally one night we were
working late and he said to me I don't
think I could keep doing this because
you know it's just not gonna be good for
me you know you know it just wasn't
gonna be good for me I guess I was
caught a little off guard but I kind of
agreed with him and I was like yeah that
seems fair because I don't want to lead
you on and I'm not ready for something
serious and clearly you are and actually
I was starting to be a little sad I was
like Dan I read is not going to talk
anymore it was like very upsetting to
imagine that our conversation and the
time we spend together was going to go
away but then of course the timing
worked out because the next week I was
in Europe the trip to Europe was I think
on is a big turning point for things
because it gave me kind of space to what
although he still managed to maintain
contact with me by having me be involved
with his video that he was doing and of
course I did have one of my best friends
Joe with me
Joe and I would just eat and drink or on
the streets of Italy and I would just
talk about the sort of non-stop the
whole time most of the time yeah Joe
gave me very very very good advice Joe
told me you know so things down a little
bit be there for her be a friend don't
be too pushy or try to make things
happen it'll happen it'll happen and I
generally do the other heart I didn't
take it as a strategy so when I came
back I knew man a human attacks on a tan
man that I didn't recognize when I saw
you
he's very tan and
as a new sense of calm and I told her I
said hey I'm sorry if I put any question
on you you know I really just want to
take things day by day and whatever
happens happens and that was genuinely
my mindset turns out that's the most
attractive thing you could possibly do
it was like he was like this new person
super mature he was just like just do
things that are on pace no pressure no
worries and I really like that once he
was back and I feel like I had space and
time I feel I got a clarity to kind of
just like look at what was it actually
happening instead of looking at what
other people were expecting to happen oh
there's no pressure like I was going on
a lot of dates I was starting to get
frustrated because the people I was
meeting couldn't really compete both in
conversational ways but also just
intellectual ways with Aria but I had
like this moment where I freaked out and
I went to Rachel's place and she was
like Rachel I went on a date last night
and I just couldn't stop thinking about
aria like I couldn't stop comparing the
guy to aria nobody makes me laugh the
way Aria does nobody gets me the way he
does I had never heard her talk about
someone this way and I was like whoa
like where is this coming from but also
like if found somebody like you really
like him dude so then one night at the
office first thing we were talking about
everything under the Sun and I broached
a topic about sexuality sexuality yes
about sex after we have a conversation
Aria had made this eye contact with me
and he just held it for an uncommon long
time and I swear to God I've never
experienced anything like this in my
life I felt so scared and aroused the
same time it was like a sexual awakening
I remember being blushing and being like
I can't even look at you right now like
I cannot look you I come back to the
office and she's just like Rachel we
need to go to the bathroom and she was
like I don't know what's going on with
me I don't know what's going on with me
but Aria gave me this look I like him
that way now I really like him after
that night I started think about Aria a
lot in a very different way my mom was
coming to town and so was my grandfather
for my birthday
Rachel was like invite Aria to come to
drinks and I was like I don't even meet
my mom we haven't even kissed I ended up
inviting him anyway you can
very dressed up had a wonderful night
touched my leg under the table while
sitting next to my mother he was very
nervous Rachel took pictures of it it
took him like 30 minutes to do it then I
started overthinking when we should have
our first kiss and where we should have
our first kiss so I took him to a park
and found a very romantic spot I also
started babbling that night I couldn't
stop and Arie grabbed my face and kissed
me was very romantic and honestly things
from there have just kind of like
skyrocketed I feel like my world for
something I was so uncomfortable with
for such a long time it was the easiest
transition in the world and then next
thing you know they're seeing Aria date
other people versus watching Aria date
Merl it just became so obvious what was
missing in the other relationships it's
like you see two people who are so
clearly right for each other
finally realize that they want to be
together and you know Merle is one of my
best friends so oh my god I'm like gonna
cry once they did decide to let
everybody know about their relationship
they did not hold back everybody knows
that we're making a video about it right
now
which anything's kind of crazy so much
of what you saw on camera was just them
in their natural element and I don't
know I'm just reading the comments and
I'm like I can't wait for the world to
find out they're actually together cuz
it's the real thing I think people have
a hard time thinking it's real because
of its value to both of their careers
but I can assure you when they're not
making money off of it they are stupid
attracted to each other
I was out celebrating girls birthday
with her and she pulls me aside and she
said I just want to let you know that I
have
serious feelings for aria no one's ever
made me happier and I could just like
feel it was true and it just made me so
happy for that good right okay I
actually have something I want to take
you to do where you're saying I leave
right now in the morning that's all you
need to know okay
Berlin Aria have the type of love that I
think a lot of people would be really
lucky to find and for how much Aria
loves romantic movies rom-coms romantic
dramas whatever I think this is a very
fitting love story for I feel like love
is a journey love is unexpected I feel
like I didn't know what love was until I
learned how terrified it was to not have
it anymore I think one of the most
important aspects of love is really
finding your best friend you need
someone to just be your teammate I think
when you have something like that it's
really special I'm a huge romantic and I
love love I think it's fascinating and
beautiful I think it's part of the whole
reason to be a human and be alive I
think love is the reason that we do
anything is to give love and ultimately
just to feel loved I've never felt this
way for someone before I didn't actually
think I could he was like in love with
the things about me that I don't even
like that much the best way I could put
it is that I think when you're
confronted with all the things you've
wanted it's hard to go after it because
you're scared that you're gonna ruin it
I've never felt more comfortable being
myself with anyone the way I am with
moral world is everything I could want
in a partner in the past few months I
have found myself really and truly
believing that I am the happiest I have
ever been
sometimes I sabotage myself in
relationships and I can actively feel
myself not doing that this time so I
guess I'm just really excited to see
what happens with me
who knows but I think this is the best
shot that I've got one of my first
videos at BuzzFeed was where I tried to
find my soulmate in 48 hours well it
took a lot more time than that
I finally got it done
[Music]
you
[Music]
high stakes for sure because now god
forbid if they were to break up there's
got to be a video about it